la question c'est de changer de mode de
vie de réinventer un mode de vie ça fait
très longtemps que je propose ça
d'ailleurs pour l'europe j'avais écrit
un livre est appelée à constituer leur
or je disais qu'il fallait inventer un
oeil au père noël live réinventer un
mode de vie et que ça qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
est ce que ça veut dire sortir du
capitalisme ou pas je pense qu'un jour
nous sortirons du capitalisme le
capitalisme est apparue ya pas si
longtemps que ça il disparaîtra je pense
pas que ce soit dans le cadre dans les
sept ans qui viennent et le gf nous
demandent que dans les temps qui
viennent ça change
et donc je pense que la vraie question
aujourd'hui c'est de repenser le modèle
industriel et de repenser la rationalité
économique en remettant en cause en
particulier je dirais moment le capital
que le travail enfin plus exactement en
remettant le travail au coeur de
l'économie et 1
réfléchissons bien ce que veut dire
travail vous avez créé à livre là-dessus
aussi j'en ai écrit d'eux mêmes de et et
le travail n'est pas ce que l'on croit
nous nous disons alors quand je dis nous
je plaide précisé qu'il ne tire pas les
gens avec qui ce travail se sont d'abord
des scientifiques mathématiques biologie
surtout ce sont des économistes ce sont
des juristes comme alain supiot ce sont
des gens assez connu des urbanistes des
sociologues comme richard sennett ça se
casse à scène enfin richard sennett qui
d'ailleurs a conseillé d'antonio
guterres espagne voilà ce sont ce sont
des gens qui savent plus tôt à sait de
quoi il parle il ya aussi des artistes
et aussi des activistes comme on dit il
ya des ingénieurs et des spécialistes du
logiciel et tous ces gens là sont
convaincus partagent une conviction
c'est que le modèle économique sur
lequel nous vivons repose sur une
physique qui totalement dépassé
c'est un modèle du xviiie siècle on
continue à résonner comme adam smith qui
lui suivait isaac newton comme une
manuelle compte mais nous ne sommes pas
après zac newton nous sommes après sadi
carnot après boltzmann après einstein
après ce running heures après beaucoup
d'autres que je ne vais pas citer
et tout ça complètement
changer le paysage scientifique
[Musique]